in a city that's long mediated between
east and west talks to over conflict
with russia the ukraine crisis
dominating a meeting of 57 nations in
vienna where there was this stark
warning the continent's not been this
close to conflict since the cold war
the risk of war
in the oec area is now greater
than ever before
in the last 30 years your excellency
there's been little progress in talks
russia's demands rejected by the west is
unacceptable it's ambassador here
insisting it's nato that's the aggressor
and the question is
what for example united states united
kingdom and other
members of alliance are doing on the
territory of ukraine by military
exercises flying
very provocative flights over the zone
of responsibility of the russians so we
shouldn't be worried by the presence of
a hundred thousand russian troops on the
border with ukraine and yet the head of
the icu today saying that we're the
closest we've been to war for 30 years
in europe uh
well this is the question to the
chairperson an office and the nato
secretary general saying yesterday that
there's a real race of armed conflict in
europe
that's that's nato is threatening with
this
we are not threatening nothing
threatening about a hundred thousand
troops on ukraine's border
thank you very much thank you very much
russia had said it would give to the end
of these meetings to give diplomacy a
chance but before this one was even over
one russian official after another has
been described in the talks as
unsuccessful and threatening alternative
measures moscow is clearly upping the
ante with the week ending pretty much as
it began
in deadlock
america is warning conflict is looming
the drum beat to war increasingly loud
in a week of talks in three different
cities no breakthrough not a glimmer of
hope this crisis is easing
dominic waghorn sky news vienna